all right people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it is july 27th
2021 and i am ready to go
today i am caffeinated i am focused
the news is so idiotic so profoundly
moronic
that i feel i'm going to give you a top
five show today normally
someone shouldn't say that at the
beginning of a show you want the
audience to make the judgment call
at the end so i'm setting the bar very
high
but i sense something good is coming we
got three stories for you
including videotape uh the covet
situation is just completely getting
bananas again like just
everything that they said a month ago
which was different than what they said
two months ago which is different from
what they said three months ago
it all seems to be just ushering right
back in now the cdc wants masks again
we're hearing that people that have the
vaccine
are getting coveted again the white
house is showing us statistics
where they don't give us any ages or
actual amounts of people they just tell
us percent
increases in debt except as i said to
ben shapiro in our interview that just
went up this morning
uh if you have one person with covet and
then you have two that's 100
increase so it sounds like a lot but
might not be that many we'll get into
that in just a sec
so there's a ton of covet stuff right up
front
then you guys know and love chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
uh she's a racist and you may remember
that about two months ago she announced
that she wasn't going to be interviewed
by anyone other than black
or brown journalists well she's doubling
down on it she just did an interview
with the new york times
the new york times and uh that's a real
place of journalism right there
and yeah she's doubling down black or
brown journalist that's it
in the name of tolerance and then
finally uh we are going to show you i i
think this is
like if you clip one thing that we do
this week and you share it with people i
think this is going to be it
there's a twitter account called i
believe it's called the libs of tic toc
is that right
libs of tick tock is that what they call
them yeah
libs of tick tock libs of tick tock on
the twitter
and they did a spectacular
spectacular nine tweet thread
with screenshots basically showing how
when trump was president
this is what we said about kovid
versus now that biden is president this
is what we say about covet related to
major news organizations places like vox
the wall street journal the washington
post
insider cnbc et cetera et cetera so
we've got the receipts and i'd like to
give credit where credit is due so
follow
at libs of tick tock on the twitter all
right before we get to any of that i
want to talk to you guys about bambi
you know when you're running a business
hr issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the list
goes on and on
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap at
an average of 70 000
bucks a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for your small
business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99
a month with bambi you can transform hr
from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees cancel any
time
if you're like me then i bet you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend all of your time on hr
compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today
go to bambi.com ruben right now to
schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
ruben spelled bam to the b-e-e dot com
slash reuben and now back to me all
right just covered
madness here is the murderous
governor of new york andrew cuomo
and we have to get in those communities
and we have to knock on those doors
and we have to convince people and put
them in a car
and drive them and get that vaccine in
their
arm that is the mission
is he a complete psychopath i mean
everything that he said there
it's very quick actually i'll read it to
you we have to knock on those doors and
we have to convince
people put them in cars and
drive them and get that vaccine in their
arm
that is the mission well i guess
cars are better than trains you see what
i did there
um cuomo is completely out of control
now first off as you know cuomo
sent dozens if not hundreds of infected
covid patients back into elder care
homes back
into old age homes we know tons of
people died
because of that if you want more info on
that you can check my interview with
janice dean fox news meteorologist whose
husband's parents both died because of
what cuomo did
by the way it turns out that the justice
department is now not going to look into
these cases
there were cases of this in michigan in
new york and i think one or two other
states
the justice department has just said
nope we're not going to do anything
about that so cuomo is going to run
scot-free on this thing
which is absolutely crazy but it's not
just
what he's saying there put them in cars
and drive them
it's the tone that he says it with that
he's he's this
god he thinks he is the king that he is
god
and that he at the end there he says
that is the mission
now i need somebody to explain something
to me i'm trying guys
i'm not a conspiracy theorist i'm not
some generally
anti-vaxxed crazy person okay i'm a
pretty middle of the road kind of guy
but you have got to explain to me why a
year and a half
later after it was two weeks to flatten
the curve which no one talks about that
did we flatten the curve does anyone
know
have we flattened the curve what was the
curve did we talk about the curve
anymore no more curves right
okay a year and a half half after that
we now know that about 99 of people
survive
covet i don't know how many times i have
to say this or everyone else has to say
this about 99
of the people and we know that the
people that die are usually in their 80s
usually have other comorbidities usually
are overweight okay often have other
diseases right and that young people
don't die young people get sick you
might be sick for a couple days that's
not to say no young people die that's
not
to say you're not going to hear the
one-off awful story
but something is very very wrong here
none of us were told say a year ago not
even a year and a half ago a year ago
hey guys we're never going to get back
to normal unless
everyone gets vaccinated by this thing
people get
sick in life there is a sickness going
throughout society that is much more
dangerous
than kovid which is the sickness that we
can somehow wipe
out risk that is a mind virus we cannot
wipe out risk guess what
people get the flu every year and people
die of the flu
people fall off roofs people get eaten
by alligators people get electrocuted
all sorts of things happen to people
okay shark attacks
all right you know a piano falling off
the roof of a building crushing someone
these are things that happen and yet we
have these insanely
authoritarian lunatics like andrew cuomo
who has
seems to have no guilt seems to have no
remorse over what he did and now he's
talking about getting
people in cars and getting needles
in their arm that is the mission and he
thinks he's the good guy
well he's not a good guy and speaking of
not good guys
here's california governor gavin newsom
it's choice to live with this virus
and with all due respect you don't have
a choice
to go out and drink and drive and put
everybody else's lives at risk
that's the equivalent
of this moment with the deadliness and
efficiency of the delta
virus you're putting other people's
innocent people's lives at risk
you're putting other people innocent
people's lives at risk because of the
deadliness of the delta virus
okay now notice he doesn't really give
you any numbers there and i'm going to
get into some percentages and numbers in
just a second
but this is more fear-mongering from a
person who at the height
of the pandemic right when thousands of
people were dying
he ate indoors with lobbyists
at one of the most expensive restaurants
in all of
the united states supposedly he spent
about
thousand dollars on food and they spent
the rumor is about twenty thousand
dollars on booze because it's up in
sonoma you know wine country area and uh
the wine ain't cheap up there
uh this man has destroyed the economy of
california i can tell you that just
where i live it's pretty it's a pretty
decent area it's not beverly hills but
it's pretty decent area
the main drag here virtually everything
is still
closed things are still boarded up there
are office buildings that
no one's ever gone back to these offices
they've destroyed the economy
every single business that is open
actually says that they're hiring but
because of moronic policies from this
guy
and joe biden with old person syndrome
we keep the government we
keep giving money to people to not work
so things like uber
for example i wonder if this is
happening to you in your town uber
in los angeles which used to take two
minutes no matter where you were you get
uber in two minutes
now takes 17 minutes takes 21 minutes
because people
don't want to work his ridiculous
comparison
to people drunk driving i'm not even
going to address that but tell me that
gavin newsom
with his slick suit and his slicked back
hair and that gravelly voice tell me
he's not
evil he's just evil i don't know what
else to tell you the guy is just evil
american
psycho evil google christian bell
american psycho
put it side by side by gavin newsom and
you tell me what's going on here
we've got some more info though uh
here's from cnbc
because this just broke this morning the
cdc is
going to reverse indoor mask policy
saying fully vaccinated people should
wear them indoors and in covet hot spots
so i just want to extrapolate once again
when everyone was told a few months ago
if you get vaccinated then we're going
to open up you're not going to wear
masks you're allowed to be indoors
outdoors you can do whatever you want
you can be in large groups of people
but then we all forget i mean partly
what i think is happening in america
right now and i suspect in the in the
wider world as well
is that we're all just forgetting things
they tell us something one week ago
and then they just tell us something
else and then we just kind of forget
what they said and we just keep
we keep doing this slow descent to hell
with these people
and that's exactly what they're doing
they're on their way to authoritarian
hell and they're grabbing us
and pulling us down into that abyss with
them
uh so you're telling me that all of
these vaccinated people suddenly they
have to wear them indoors
because of covet hot spots and whatever
else whatever else they're saying
again i am not sitting here telling you
that i have every answer
related to vaccines or exactly what we
should do
related to covid but the cdc
at this point should say hey we'd like
you to get the vaccine
but also let's show you what the actual
numbers are and let's show you
how many less deaths there are now than
there were at the height of this thing
that curve even though nobody talks
about the curve
down okay it curved down okay partly
because of
herd immunity partly because most people
get a little sick you get a cough you
get a cold
you get a sore throat and then you're
okay and all the other reasons that i
mentioned up front if you're not
overweight and you're not
you don't have other diseases and
everything else but what they're doing
is they're
fiddling with numbers so i just saw this
right before we started i tweeted about
it i saw a tweet
by a girl named caitlin collins she is
the chief
white house correspondent for cnn and
cnn is a fake news organization that's
on your local cable channel i don't have
a cable box anymore
uh and this is what she tweeted and then
we're gonna and i want you to look at
the image as well
i'll unpack that in a sec here's what
she tweeted sign up in the white house
briefing room
ahead of new cdc guidance on masks and
then she goes all caps people
so you know it's important virtually all
hospitalizations and deaths are among
unvaccinated people now first off this
woman
purports to be a journalist she's the
chief white house correspondent
of uh over at cnn over there now does
that strike you this capitalization
thing is she trying
to calmly give you information or is she
trying to make you crazy with all caps
now interestingly put the image up
please okay now in this image that you
can see here
what they're giving you is so it says
virtually all hospitalizations they
spelled hospitalizations wrong
and deaths are among among unvaccinated
people
and then they show you a couple things
from florida ohio
north carolina and colorado and you're
not going to believe this and this is
why everyone is so stupid
these days they're showing you here
percentages so in florida
95 of those hospitalized were not
vaccinated
okay 95 of them but how many people was
it four people
was it a thousand people was it twenty
thousand people and the same thing in
all of these
99 percent in ohio covid 19 deaths okay
how old are they are they all
90 year olds are they 90 year olds that
also have cancer i mean give us
some information but what this caitlyn
collins does and i'm not trying to make
it about her
but she's supposed to be a journalist so
the white house puts something up there
they spell hospitalizations wrong you
amplify it you put
all caps meaning oh my god all the sky
is falling once again
chicken little where's turkey lurkey
everyone's freaking out
and then they did it i mean i can read
it again with north carolina it's the
same thing
colorado 96 of their covid 19
hospitalizations okay
how old is everyone are they sick
otherwise
were they hit by cars on the way in and
happen to have coven
like nobody is i'm not a data scientist
but nobody is analyzing anything
remotely honestly and they are trying to
make us
crazy and by the way guys they are never
ever going to stop you know i always say
and i was saying it go back and watch my
videos three weeks into covet guys the
old world's not coming back
these people are enjoying they really
are not making about this caitlyn girl
but these people are enjoying this
endless control this endless game it's
giving them purpose
right like it's giving them something to
live for because they've decided to live
for
nothing else other than government
control and fear
and and paranoia and anxiety i refuse to
live that way
and i think you refuse to live that way
it's partly why i do my august off the
grid which can't come soon enough
this year uh and we've got to just keep
fighting this like
you know i said it the other day i don't
like giving energy to this sort of thing
but maybe these people have to live in
their hyper
vaccinated every three-month booster
shot not seeing other people
masked up bubbles and the rest of us
will build just a parallel society and
you know what's gonna happen in that
parallel society people are gonna smile
people are gonna go to work people are
gonna be happy they're gonna teach their
children
true things and life will go on
all right story number two lori
lightfoot this woman is
just absolutely awful there's no
other way to describe it she has
continued
the destruction of chicago can we find
out how many people were shot in chicago
this weekend we like to do that
because uh tons of people are shot in
chicago every weekend dozens and dozens
sometimes upwards of 100 people usually
about 10 or so deaths we'll get the
numbers in just a second oh you got the
numbers for me oh this is a good one
this is a good one damn we don't have
the uh the music for uh the deaths in
chicago yet we're working on that
play a little sort of game show music
when i talk about deaths in chicago um
104 people
were shot in chicago this past weekend
19
dead i don't see any protests anywhere
i don't see anyone demanding lori
lightfoot
step down i don't see anyone screaming
about racist
police so what let me think for a second
what could be going on here could it be
a people
that people of a certain color or people
are shooting at people of a certain
color and that doesn't fit the narrative
so we don't talk about that sort of
thing
i think that might be it all right so
we've got audio from
uh the new york times podcast of chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
doubling down on her insanely
racist decision to only be interviewed
by people of color take a listen back in
may mayor lightfoot announced that on
the occasion of the two-year anniversary
of her inauguration she would grant
one-on-one interviews exclusively to
journalists of color
she faced a lot of heat for it how do
you feel about
the the reaction to that um you're being
sued some people including prominent
journalists of color
called it a stunt why did you tell me
why you did that why are you talking to
me
like i'm a white lady so here's the the
bottom line for me
to state the obvious i'm a black woman
mayor i'm the mayor of the third largest
city in the country
obviously have a platform it's important
to me to advocate on things
that i believe are important and going
back to why i ran
to disrupt the status quo the media is
critically important to our democracy
you know this better than i do the media
is in a time of incredible
upheaval and disruption but our city
hall press corps
looks like it's 1950 or 1970.
when i look across the podium whether
i'm in a formal press conference
or i'm out in a neighborhood the
reporters who show up
are invariably overwhelmingly white
intentionality around diversity and
inclusion
is crucial people that make the hiring
decisions
have to be focused on diversity
modern racism ladies and gentlemen
brought to you
by the tolerant and diverse democratic
party i want to be very clear about this
nobody except these people nobody except
the woke progressives cares that she's
black nobody cares
she became mayor nobody cares nobody
cares that she's a woman
she became mayor nobody cares nobody
cares that she's a lesbo
she became mayor nobody cares she's a
black female lesbian mayor
nobody gives a flying [ __ ] except her
and her cohorts to use her identity
as a wedge issue to make the rest of us
feel racist
while she's the one who acts racist
that's what these people are and they
should be
ignored that's what they have to be they
have to be ignored
i don't even know why she was sitting
down with a white woman apparently this
interviewer was a white woman so i guess
she doesn't even believe the drivel that
she's putting out there
or she can put it aside if it's a
podcast as big as the new york times i
don't know that they have a big podcast
i don't know anyone that listens to new
york times or pays attention
to the new york times at this point but
i suppose they do or at least they fake
numbers like they fake numbers on their
new york times bestseller list
um but i guess she put it aside i will
sit with you
evil white devil to get my message out
about how you people are the evil white
devils
ridiculous all right well all of this i
think today has led us to
uh what i mostly talk about here which
is that the media the corporate press
lies to you about everything they lie
about absolutely everything no matter
what hoax they're coming up with
they love their narrative you guys know
it all kavanaugh's a
serial rapist the covington kids are
racist
jesse smallett was lynched uh
trump is working for russia all the
things that we weren't allowed to
or that we had to say were true under
trump now we're not allowed to talk
about just like
the endless cascade of ridiculousness
well there's this twitter feed
called uh libs of tick tock and they
just did a great job here so what we're
gonna show you is a nine tweet thread
the image that you're gonna see on your
left is what they were saying
under trump and the image that you're
gonna see on the right
is the is what they're now saying under
biden and these are all mainstream news
organizations i'm going to read each
headline and you tell me
if perhaps some of these places of
journalism
change their opinion because it was
their guy in the white house and now
scary orange man was gone so we'll start
with vox
this is june 2020 on the left the effect
of black lives matter protests on
coronavirus cases
explained coronavirus cases are
increasing but black lives matter
protests may not be to blame
here's why huh okay now let's back let's
go to january 21.
now biden's in office the attack on the
capital may have also been a super
spreader event
lawmakers may have been exposed to the
coronavirus during wednesday's riot
okay so when trump's in office and it's
black lives matter protest
no no no no one's getting coveted
biden's in office
now covid superspreader
wall street journal june 2020
early data showed no uptick in covid19
transmission
from protests public health experts say
preliminary test results are encouraging
outdoor locations and masks may have
helped well that's wonderful
now let's go to january 2021 wall street
journal
at least three lawmakers test positive
after
uh for covet 19 after capital attack
democratic house members sheltered in
room where republicans
refused to wear masks so again
black lives matter protest we're all
good
no more black lives matter protests
protesting over something else we got a
problem
let's go to forbes july 2020
research determines protests did not
cause spike in coronavirus cases here's
forbes in january 21 lawmakers
sheltering during capital riot may have
been exposed to coronavirus
guys are you getting what's going on
here yet are you are you picking up what
i'm dropping
okay this is some fine work libsy tiktok
very proud of you
here's cnn which is a fiction
news network uh june 2020
black lives matter protests have not led
to a spike in coronavirus cases
research says january 2021
cnn 38 capital police officers test
positive for covet 19 after capital riot
my god covid knows your political
leanings and infects you
accordingly it's incredible usa today
june 20th june 2020 coronavirus surges
aren't linked to black lives matter
protests
january 2021 usa today
wednesday's storming of the u.s capitol
will likely
be a surge event for the coronavirus
said
dr robert redfield director of the
centers for disease control and
prevention he told mcclatchy in an
interview that he's worried because
thousands of people did not wear masks
and have since left washington for
various parts of the country
uh well robert redfield if you're
watching this i would love to know did
you
say the same thing when it was black
lives matter protests or didn't you
because people getting together
in big groups regardless of their
political affiliation you'd think the
virus would spread the same way
i'm not a scientifician or a man the
magician just a guy you know
new york times july 2020.
did floyd protests lead to a virus surge
here's what we know
epidemiologists have braced for a surge
of coronavirus cases
but it has not come yet how convenient
january 2021 new york times
did mixing a riot with the pandemic
yield a super spreader event
members of a mob many unmasked roamed
the halls of a cab of the capital
unmasked republicans jammed into secure
rooms the outcome is worrisome to many
members of congress
insider i believe this used to be
business insider january 2020
don't blame black lives matter protests
for spike in coronavirus
cases across the us january 2021
business insider
the capital insurrection seems to have
caused a super spreader event among
lawmakers some republicans refuse to
mask up
my head is going to explode the
washington post
june 2020 protests probably didn't lead
to coronavirus spikes but it's hard to
know for sure
january 2021 storming of the capital was
textbook potential coronavirus super
spreader
experts say and finally
no sorry not finally we got three more
cnbc june 2020 house gop
leader suggests without evidence that
protests are driving up coronavirus
cases
january 2021 coveted killing nearly 3
000 in u.s every day as
cdc warns of surge event from capitol
riots my god abc news they wanted to get
in on it
minis uh june sorry june 2020
minnesota sees no rise in covet cases
tied to protests health official
spectacular uh abc january 2021
capitol hill riot could prove to be
covet 19
super spreader event experts say
and finally the last one just in case
you're slow and you don't get what's
going on here the final one
the associated press which by the way
shares offices with hamas in gaza
little evidence that protests spread
coronavirus in the u.s of course that
was july 2020
and in january 2021 possible virus
exposure for
lawmakers sheltering during riot
we are in an information war
and it is your job if you're gonna be a
functional
remotely sane human being in this war if
you're going to survive
and you're going to thrive in this crazy
time that we live in
it is your job unfortunately to see
through the [ __ ] it is your job
to do a little extra work to know when a
headline is lying to you and
experts say this this time an expert say
that last time
and suddenly we don't cover this story
because it doesn't fit the narrative
and when a story fits the narrative so
much we push the hell out of it only to
find out a month later it's not even
true
it's your job we're we're all in this
war like like this
is it this what i just did right there
and i think what actually the whole show
was about today
this is what it's all about we are in a
complete
reality war as a certain set of people
are trying to take away our rights scare
the hell out of us make us afraid of
each other keep
us masked keep us indoors make sure
we're getting booster shots every
three weeks and god knows what else is
coming
and if you have stayed remotely sane
in the last year and a half
bravo bravo because we got to keep going
people
we got to keep going speaking of people
that did stay
sane in the last year and a half part
one of my interview with the fastest
talking jew on
all of the internet ben shapiro is up
right now the full episode is up
at reubenreport.locals.com ben's new
book which came out this week i think
it's coming out i think it's today right
if i'm not mistaken comes out today
so we drop in shapiro the day it comes
out it's called the authoritarian moment
and it's a really interesting read and
in many ways it feels
ben and i did not plan this but you know
my book came out last
april april 2020 of course don't burn
this book
ben's book actually feels a little bit
almost like a follow-up to it and
my new book which we're going to
announce the title and the pre-sale on
friday
actually feels like the next step in
that so there's a little bit of a
trilogy feeling there
but you can check out the authoritarian
moment wherever books are sold
um my big off the grid friday direct
message
we're gonna do probably like a two hour
show we will be
selling pre-sales of the book signed
copies numbered copies
signed and numbered copies for those of
you that are members at ruben
report.locals.com
signed copies for everybody else that
buys it on day one we're really going to
try to crush it and knock it out of the
park i can't wait to share the cover
with you guys in the title and the whole
thing
and then we have uh at least one big
announcement related
to locals and then i disappear for a
month i come back on september 1st with
adam carolla who will get me up to speed
and of all years you know it's always
weird there's always stuff that goes on
things happen you know the big news last
year was whap
became the number one song in america
what's her name who was it who's the
girl that did it
cardi b and she's got this wet dripping
thing and a bucket and the whole thing
that was like the big story that i
missed last year but this year it feels
like oh she's got a mop and a bucket
it's all it's a whole thing
but this year it feels like literally
anything could happen like biden's
eyeball could just explode in the middle
of one of speech
you know and kamala could be president
you know china could just completely
take over
like what what could i possibly come
back to on september 1st
that would shock me like there's almost
nothing at this point because everything
is so bad it's like
we're gonna half the population is
wrapping their head in saran wrap like
possible anything's possible anything's
possible listen guys i don't think i
over promised at the beginning of the
show i feel this one was solid
focused we gave you what you came for
you didn't even have to pay a dime
what a world what a world all right if
you want to play along with me
throughout the day
robinreport.locals.com
and i'll see you tomorrow